good to see you all my name's James were
from England so won't surprise you that
his first joke is about apricots you
knew it since I open my mouth you like a
great is another apricot routine to
listen to another Brit bang on about
apricot so now I don't make any
apologies we love apricots you know that
and regs it is all we love no they
brought some ready-to-eat apricots the
other day
you call them dried apricots flew we
call them ready-to-eat apricots because
that's how much we love apricots in
Britain were like when when can i I need
to know when I can I immediately will
put it on the bag then put it on the bag
and what I'm on my teeth so bad Boston
ready-to-eat apricots the other day
trying to be more healthy they say you
are what you eat which is true because
as soon as abort they're ready to eat
apricots I was ready to eat apricots
it's ready to be apricots they came into
V sealable bag as well because not
everyone is ready to eat apricots as
they think they are
maybe next time they're by ready to eat
some apricots yeah man
listen I was at a house party recently
cuz back in the UK I'm something of a
high flyer I'm there I know they go to
parties Antonio stay at home I drink on
my own
Fairplay I love it not the front door to
get myself a glass of punch is that way
it wouldn't punch on my own it's that
strange
I don't whatever people I took it from a
massive punch while we were ladle in it
in the corner of my bedroom is that I
don't know whatever people do people was
worried about punch getting spiked so
low punch top and solved
despite myself unless its funtime
Thursdays I'd get hammered don't worry I
don't get mega trashed on my own and
blasted I just get tipsy tipsy the best
thing can be in life is tipsy there's
four things could be in life
sober tipsy drunk hungover tip seems the
only one out of the four where you don't
cry doing it some of the jokes are sad I
should have warned you some of the jokes
are sad you got sad as well I'm sorry
you got sustained if you gettin tipsy
make sure every other drinks of soughing
sustain it maintain it I'm a dr. pepper
man I love dr. pepper I don't claim to
understand it I'm not that arrogant what
on an enigma that drink is I drink it
every night I couldn't tell you what
flavor is so mystery have it in my mouth
of all my senses shut up I'll be like it
tastes like a sexy battery are you happy
it's like a sexy battery the sexiest
battery I ever did taste the can says
mixed fruit flavor how stupid do they
think we I wasn't born yesterday I know
what food tastes like heard fruit before
never send a fruit said the backs it was
to dr. pepper II that is a liar habits
really funny I said most food backs is
to dr. pepper just to see how they bring
it back and what they change you'll
learn a lot about a chef it's party man
I was chatting this guy worst person so
is the worst
this guy's the worst the worst and I
don't say that lightly by the way
there's over seven billion people in the
world he's my best guess for the worst
someone's the worst you forget that
don't you someone is the worst everyone
in the world someone is the worst one
someone and they don't even know it
either they have no idea none of us know
who the worst is it's definitely a man
no one's arguing that but beyond that no
clues
unlucky fellas you're the worst you
should realize it by now have any idea
how hard a woman would have to work to
become the worst round the-clock so much
commitment and dedication for women
became the worst it was so impressive
she'd become the best that is how hard
to have two words would come with worse
well done Susan congratulations you've
put so much effort into it now you are
the worst that makes you the best and
that guy over there is now the worst who
never puts any effort into anything but
always lands on his feet congratulations
this guy was the worst was talking to
you kept telling me these stories and
every story started the same it'd be a
version of this it always go I was in
the bar right and these two Chinese guys
walked in and said Chinese guys I'm just
like man I hope that's relevant
please be relevant that they're Chinese
please did God never it's okay it's
halfway through the stories like and
then they taught me Mandarin and it was
heartwarming never that nice thing that
happens it was just like basically paint
them in a bit of a bad light he's giving
you both bits of information that
they're Chinese they did something bad
and he steps away like you connect the
dots I will do you are a racist man that
is very easy to connect those two dots
naturally don't make sure someone's
racing a story if it's not relevant to
please performer I find it offensive
that people are they're thrown in
irrelevant details it distracts the
audience from the narrative of the story
you kind of listen to the story but all
you're doing is scanning it for
relevance for the whole thing don't do
that that's why if I have another story
I'll keep people's race to the end as a
twist I get like the end of the story
and I'm like and that guy was Bulgarian
you guys have been lovely I'll come back
here soon and hang out with every single
one of you good bye
[Applause]
you